sean newcomb opened in his fourth start
of 2020 01 with a 657 era phil gosling
the dh and the leadoff man for the
fillings
opposite way or cake is shaded that way
it doesn't matter it drops in for a hit
phil gosling gets the first inning
started with a lead off single for the
phillies and he's at first base for
reese hoskins
to left field that's a base hit for
hoskins
gosling on his way to third here comes
the throw it's offline aggressive based
running
philly's at first and third with nobody
out
bryce harper hitting 267 two home runs
five rbis
out toward right center field going back
on it as a cunha junior that one is long
gone
into the frames
[Music]
a three-run home run for bryce harper
and the phillies jump out to the early
lead
that was a
blast crazy thing about grigorius he has
four or five swings and misses all year
that's it this is their 11th game
puts into play and did right there what
a stop freeman race to the bag and he
got there just ahead of didi gregorius
great job by freddy kind of slid in and
got that edge right here you can see
right there gets it right before
gregorius with a headfirst slide into
first base and that may have cost him
and the pitch is right there and it's
hit well to left center field deep back
toward the wall that ball is out of here
travis tarnow continues his blistering
pace
a long home run off the bat of the
braves catcher his second of the year
and the braves answer right back with a
long ball themselves 3-1 game here comes
roman quinn the ninth place hitter
there's a liner to left field by robin
quinn is it high enough it is gone
it was high enough
that got out of here in a hurry his
first home run of the year
and the phillies are back on top by
three
that's the swing he needs to take just a
hard line driving just got out of here
in a hurry and it'll bring up bryce
harper said harper with a three-run home
run his first time up
that got the hand of bryce harper
oh no
it was a change up but it got in on his
hand or his wrist he's down on one knee
but a member of the training staff and
joe gibrani now right on top of harper
all right he's putting his helmet on
and heading over to first base that is a
good sign yes indeed
to left field that'll be in for a hit
gosselin held up at third just to make
sure it wasn't caught so he could tag he
scores easily rbi single by jt romunto
his tenth of the year the phillies
leading 5-1 the bases are loaded and
indeedy at the plate facing erlang
and a high fly ball to deep right field
marches going back it is gone
upgrade slam for dede
the phillies have busted it open here in
the second on top nine to one what a
beautiful swing a towering home run
here's segura
this one to right field marcake is going
back again toward the scoreboard that
one's gone
sailing out of the yard
on opposite field home run for segora
and the phillies
have reached double digits here in the
second inning it's 10-1
in the summer when it gets hot the ball
flies out of here and i mean they are
jumping and now jt romuto jt singled his
last time up
and he didn't single this time he
crushed one to deep left field
his fifth home run of the year the ball
is absolutely jumping here at citizens
bank park
demarco to start the sixth inning
swing and a miss he actually did get a
piece of it hung on to by jt
sixth strikeout here's a danny
echeverria his first at bat the ball's
two strikes and the pitch
sway gonna miss he got him what a nasty
curve seven strikeouts for aaron and the
braves go down one two three adam duvall
the batter three and two here's the
a call pitch
three
93 miles an hour two out strikeout
number nine
so here's riley who's one for two
swag and a miss he throws the change up
another double digit strikeout
performance for aaron noah it's back to
back double digit k's
in a game for the philly's right-hander
five hits for atlanta in the inning and
it's 13 to five and nick marcake is
coming up is hammer that's fair and
headed for the corner it's going to be
13-6
his 500th career double
comes in the ninth inning and nick
marcakis wants that baseball
as he should 500 doubles
that is tough to do and it's up to
austin riley to keep the game alive
riley unloads a hanging slider and he
hit it to the liberty bell
it's 13-8 a two-run homer
braves aren't dead yet
seven for atlanta in the ninth
over to first base that's a fair ball jt
was hugging the line he's in perfect
place he makes the play and the ball
game is finally over billy's winning
13-8